يشهد معبر قلابات مجمع على الحدود
الاثيوبيه السودانيه مزيد من التدفق من
القادمين من الخرطوم حيث وصل امس 1600 شخص
قلابات الى المجمع والله زعلان جديد
لانه الناس هذه بتتشاكل ده يعني
ما متشاكلين مع ناس تانيين او مع دوله
ثاني سودانيين بقتلوا بعض يعني يعني دعم
السريع سوداني والجيش سوداني
يعني انا بس بتمنى من شنو بتمنى
اقرب زمن ان شاء الله هذا الحرف ده بينتهي
طلعنا بعد اول اسبوع ما في كهرباء ما في
مويه طلعنا من خطا من الخرطوم رحنا
القضارف قعدنا زي اربعه يوم في القضارف
مجموعه كبيره نطلع معاها لما لقينا مجموعه
كبيره طلعنا طوالي جينا هنا الحمد لله
يعني الاوضاع ما كانت سيئه شديد لكن
المشكله ان في زحمه
وان كل المسافرين كان حديثهم مليء
بالاحباط وذكريات ماساويات ماساويه وقصص
مليئه بالعبر وتحدثوا عن معاناه كبيره
عاشوها على مدار هذه الايام واصوات الطلق
والرصاص وعاشوا على واقع عدواء اطلاق
النار المتبادله واصوات الطيارات
والصواريخ المضاده للطيارات والامر كان
معقدا وصعبا للقاء عليهم بعد ان تركوا
حياتهم واحلامهم التي بنوها على مدى سنوات
في السودان من جنسيات مختلفه
وهناك من ترك ممتلكاته وهناك من تركه
مسانعه من ترك حياته وكلهم وصلوا الى هذه
المكان بحثا عن الامان
محمد طه توكل الجزيره
المتامه على الحدود الاثيوبيه السودانيه